[Music]
and seven I will be talking about how we
package deploy and run a patch of
Spartan applications on my box so let's
start with what the problem is for those
of you who are not familiar with what
matte box does we provide SDKs it guys
employed for developers who want to
integrate Maps Navigation in their
applications to this day you have a 1
million registered developers and this
means that we collect data back from
around 300 million applications running
that box and this actually maps out to
be around 220 million miles of
anonymized mobile location on a day so
obviously that's a huge amount of data
but today I'm not gonna be talking about
how we deal with those large amounts of
data I'm going to be talking about a
whole different problem how do we give
everyone at map box access to this data
that were collecting so that they can
make data-driven decisions and they can
harvest this data and make use of it so
we figured out that there's a huge wide
range of use cases people want to run
experiments on and they want to penalize
it aggregated transformer in Korea and
even right between learning elements
against it so it's a very diverse use
case so we here at the data engineering
team decided that we needed to provide
map box with a unified data platform and
the reason kind of this is though so
that we that the engineering team can
remove ourselves as a blocker to towards
the state up so that we can give
everyone at that box the ability to
build their own pipelines to go their
own data processing applications so that
we're no longer a barrier so that
everyone can have access to this data
and we can make very good data driven
decisions of map box so the data
platform that we want to build would
have to have to do a lot it would have
to have
the ingestion of this data it would have
to handle storage the data processing
and and would have to provide tools for
analysis and as we started building this
out we started to realize that Apache
spark is going to be a very key
component of this infrastructure and
what attracted us to spark is because of
its data processing capabilities that we
all know of but also that it has our
sequel and an additional libraries like
Emma left that spark provides we also
realize that for us to be successful
people at matte box would have to adopt
this technology and we have to adopt
this new tech that we're adding to stack
which is spark and we realized that if
you model something around something
that's already familiars everyone
they're more likely to adopt it and
they're more likely to use it and that
means we're more successful because our
major goal is to have everyone adopt
this new technology and adopt this new
platform that we're building
so our underlying goal after all of this
is that we want all of our users to
develop iceberg applications just like
they would any other piece of software
map box so all the tooling and all in
the infrastructure that we would have to
build would have to be geared around
that how do we make packaging and
deploying and building smart
applications be just like any other
piece of software in my box so let's
start by taking a look at what our data
pipeline looks like we have data coming
in in an ingestion and it all lines up
into our data Lake which is a stream and
then we have these spark applications
which we call data transformation
applications that take to stay that from
s3 it cleans it up defines a schema
around it partitions it and writes it to
the file down warehouse we use this tool
called I'm mixing I wish I'm gonna be
talking about that allows us to manage
these spark applications and actually
all spark applications are deployed in
that box and then the spark allocations
also use a Python module that we have
built and that's installed on all of our
spark clusters called MDX part and the
reason we have NEX part is to ensure
that we're writing to both of our
ministers
glue and hive in the same manner and if
you're wondering why we have too many
stars is because of the diversity case I
had mentioned we have Allen school of
Athena
and you know Athena is great for for
writing sequel queries so we need to
have glue which Pasadena and then we
also have hive which basically powers
the spark applications that people are
writing I'm a bus and are part of the
data pipelines that we have that map box
as well so this is yes this is basically
what the processing part of our data
pipeline looks like so what does
building spark applications at map box
look like we as I mentioned we have this
thing called a mix data and what I'm
being stated is is the command-line tool
that we have built that is basically the
gateway to our data warehouse it is like
how everyone at mapbox
interacts with their data if you don't
have the MPX data you don't have access
to our data and this gave us a lot of
power to onboard people really easily
and to have everyone use our data in one
in one way so the three commands I'll be
focusing on today are MDX data felt and
that what that does is it builds a
bundle of your spark application
and that bundle has everything it needs
to run in production and also be talking
about them to exceed or run which
actually allows you to run that bundle
on a real spark cluster and then finally
on the Xterra deploy which allows you to
schedule all those smart applications
and this command-line tools what was
built with node.js so at the beginning
is this so again like I have a reiterate
that we want everyone to build spark
equations just like they would any other
application you start really get herb
repo and you start writing your sprite
application and then once you have your
logic in there and have your spark
application and the it's data requires
you to write a Java configuration and
the reasoning behind why we enforce this
Java configuration is because it
basically tells of a state on what it
needs to build and run your application
so if we take a look at what this
configuration looks like and the first
walk up there is to run time because we
allow actually Python to Johnson Python
3 and so that's what that's there for
and then we also have these things the
parameters object and that is for
runtime parameters so for parameters
that are going to change over the life
cycle of your application and you don't
want to actually put them in your
application you want to be able to like
supply two values of these parameters as
you're building your application and the
final and of course if you have
sensitive information like API keys that
you do not want it to be committed to
github you can provide them at runtime
the final object there with the Java ski
that's the list of jobs that you could
have in your spark repo so we allow like
multiple jobs and that's how you would
define which Java switch and the
constraint here is that like job on the
score one has to match the name of the
the Python file of the main function for
the sprint application so now you have
your spark application is gonna get her
repo and you have a job configuration
associated with it then the next stuff
to do is that you actually want to build
this application so you can run in
production so you type in FBX data built
and you provide an environment name and
what the environment name does is it
just fills a stack according to that
built so in this example I'm using
production and we're building a
production bundle and the first step
that happens there is that your job
configuration is validated and once
that's determined to be validated you're
actually prompted for your runtime
variables that were defined in the Java
configuration so you would define the
values for those tiny variables or
runtime parameters and then whatever the
XD the bill does is that it packages all
this information into a payload so in
that payload we have like the github
repo information the build environment
name which in this case is production
and then the key and values for the
parameters JSON so what are the exhibit
Bill does with this payload it actually
triggers alarm done cold spork I mean
what spark does is it creates a bundle
that is rentable on a patch of spark and
and delivers it to s3 so as we saw like
that what the payload has in there is
this exactly probably per name which is
spark up and build environment name
which is production and then the
parameters JSON was just like the key
and value of the parameters that you
passed in as a user and then it will
build a stream path for where it wants
to put that bundle on a street and if
you don't know what that stream path
looks like it's it's a combination
name the staff name which is production
and then a gift shop Ramshaw unique
identifier and the gift shop is actually
the kitchen show up your latest commit
and yeah the pressure is just generated
from the parameters file so the reason
we do this is to create this like track
of bundles that you are putting on the
street so that you know if you're
developing like machine learning models
and you want to track actually like what
every build but as you're iterating over
your model you can definitely do that
so every realm creates its only new
bundle on s3 and there's a trace of all
those bundles so once that s3 path is
built and determined one spark will do
next is it will start generating all the
bundle contents and what those are is
like the parameters file the
dependencies which is from the
requirements of txt and spark
application Python files and then a
dynamically generated init script which
points to that I mention point of your
spark application and then it finally
triggers an AWS good luck and what code
build simply does is it pulls in the
dependencies from the requirements of
txt and put bills a big bundled awesome
with all those components so once you
have this bundle on a stream that is has
everything your application needs to run
on production you could even do have the
extender run or MDX state and deploy and
the difference between the two is run
walls or running your application on an
Apache on a spark cluster and we'll show
you the results and a next type of
deployment will actually schedule it so
the difference in the prompt is that
deploy will ask you how often do you
want a schedule list and we'll pull the
schedule and we actually use cue ball
which is a
Dana sermons are in a platform to manage
our spark clusters and so we use their
API to submit our jobs to do sweat
Buster's so on the next day to run and
deploy mainly view is they build the
sparks of med string and for those of
you who are familiar with spark spark
cement is actually as a script available
also our clusters allows you to submit
applications terms so the smart submit
string looks like this the thinking peg
is like the spark configuration so user
would pass to spark so they want to
override them to optimize so for their
applications and then the Python files
are all in the bundled on set so this is
where the build staff comes in and then
finally like the hit script which is the
entry point to your application and then
the name of the job that you want to run
so if we take a step back and take a
look at what deploying and running
spread out faces look like a matte box
so yeah you start with your github repo
that has your spark application and job
creation someone you're writing a test
against those we provide all spark repos
with a docker file that sets up high
spark and high for you and then you try
to expand a film which does template
validation ask you for runtime
parameters and put step on the long test
we using the length of score once a
bundle is on s3 and the extender running
to point can touch to that bundle and
run it on a real spark cluster which we
managed to sinkable and we use 200
stores glue and hives so that we can run
the athena and allow our users to run to
write their only start processing jobs
so wrapping up we basically build built
this process that's around deploying
spark applications and by doing it in a
way that's familiar to everyone at
MapBox we were successful with having
more people adopt it quickly and using
something like people really helped us
get there quicker because they had a
maturity I don't instantly
- and we lost our tooling was basically
make mostly built around technology
already familiar went so that actually
enabled us to get to our goal pretty
quickly
I'm not sure if we have any like real
Costas like it was actually all pretty
smooth because as I said like we have
the stack that we're familiar with that
not boxing we have years and years of
experience with building he say llantas
and code build and stuff like that and
so I can't say like we ever ran into
like oh this doesn't work because we
were already familiar with the
technology quite thoroughly you see
changes
absolutely so by enabling like different
teams to build their own with pipelines
like we were no longer the blocker so
there were no longer like waiting on us
to raise our jobs or anything like that
so it's just like paralyzed the process
quite happily and yeah and so we just
saw like people that like even haven't
even heard of just like writing or
almost mark applications and letting
them know this is really great
bingo architecture again we saw them
like 3/4 of their product and then I see
there is a sudden third-party quality
people there I was wondering if you
considered something like so we're
migrating up okay Omar this is this
whole a big part of this process was to
get off my Myanmar we just we found EMR
a little bit like hard to manage and
it's not very user friendly so if you
know our goal here is to have a lot of
people use the stuff that we're building
so having a UI like pupils you I don't
know if you're familiar with them but it
allows you to rate notebooks and and
write like really interactive our jobs
and you can see like the feedback right
away so for us to build something that's
usable by people who are not familiar
with spark we needed to use something
like cue ball rather than any more
yeah it wasn't about us how do you
experience they how do you like the glue
because and I know they I used to work
the glue and it's it's about June last
year you know that hate and yeah it's
been pretty good so far like we use it
mainly because we we like Athena a lot
so if integrates really well with Athena
of the api's that's around gloom are
really good so like I mentioned that we
use mbx spark which is like our only
Python module that writes to blue and
high up in the same way and make sure
both ministers are insane so yeah so
that you guys are great like we could
write to glue from our code and yeah I
don't know it's been a pretty good
experience of life and so you just
mentioned so you you will give up EMR
and the two other colors so we'll
integrate we always tell glue does it in
your market okay well of glue as I
mentioned I mean long EMR cluster oh
yeah I know a good point so cue ball
does not integrate with glue so that's
why we have to have hive as well because
yeah the unfortunately people isn't
integrated with
you